Now, let's look at a very similar case, where I'm going to visualize the execution of the queue
as a finite state machine, but now we're going to have a much larger queue.
We're going to have a queue that stores a thousand elements instead of two.
We're going to have exactly the same kind of state machine, but its shape is changed.
Instead of containing 3 nodes, it contains 1001 and so, I left out a vast area of state in the middle,
and so when we randomly test this queue, we still are going to start at the empty state.
It looks like with the dynamic side at this time.
Here I have a queue with N = 1000 and nothing else has change
When we run the random testing, this time we've done around 50,000 adds to a non-full queue,
and we haven't done any adds to a full queue.
We've done almost 50,000 removes from a non-empty queue and 10 removes from an empty queue.
So, let's try to understand what happened here.
So, what happened is and I'm going to come up with another view of that state machine.
So, here we have the empty queue and here we have the full queue.
and here we have the number of times we visit a particular state.
and what's happening is with 50% probability we're randomly walking back or forward
and we're going to be getting a situation where the probability of visiting queue
states farther away from where we started drops off exponentially and actually they're good close
form equations for being the probability of getting to any particular point,
but as we saw using 100,000 tests, I believe, we never actually manage to make to 1000.
Although, we did perfectly easily make it to a queue size of two.
So, 1000 is particularly a large size for a data structure,
we could easily have some sort of a queue to have 10,000 or 100,000 elements
and the chances of randomly walking all the way out to the end become even more negligible
and so the question we're going to have ourselves is,
What do we have to do differently to a random tester to make sure to test this situation
as thoroughly as tested to this situation and so there is no common answer to this kind of question.
These kind of questions definitely are hard in practice and when something changes
about the software under test, we might have to adjust the probabilities to compensate.
Let's just look at one possible solution.
One possible solution would be to bias the probabilities towards enqueueing.
If the random number generator returns a number less than 0.6 instead of 0.5,
we're going to enqueue and the other 40% of the time, we're going to dequeue.
So, let's see what effect that has.
So this time, we attempted to add a list to full queue a large number of times,
but this time, we seem to have not particularly well tested the case of removing from an empty queue
and let's run it one more time and see what happens.
Yeah--so this time we didn't remove it from an empty queue anytime so we biased the probabilities
too far towards adding, and what's going to happen is in any kind of random walk is
as long as the probabilities are respectably balance it's going to take a long time to get somewhere
unless we unbalance the probabilities significantly like we did with the 60-40 distribution.
What they're probably doing in this case is make a configurable biased probability
and now add a completely new random testing loop.
We're now going to set that bias variable to be something sort of large unless x is odd.
If x is odd, we're going to set the bias variable to be something less.
Okay, so let's look at what we did.
We took a random testing loop and we enclose it in a larger random testing loop
and in that larger to random testing loop, we sort of made qualitative change to one of the probabilities
that is to say we bias execution towards one of our API call in favor of the other
and on even-numbered calls, we biased it the other way.
So, what we're hoping to do now is create a situation where start of in the empty state,
we migrate with pretty high probability towards full and bounce around there,
and at the end of that particular configuration of the testing run,we're going to walk back
We're going to do that, I believe, 20 times.
And so what we hope is that this will test even for the fairly large queue
a lot of its possibilities so let's see if that actually happens.
So of course, this is going to take longer to run this time.